la sfl la distillerie la favorite est
condamné par le tribunal correctionnel à
une amende de cent cinquante mille euros
pour avoir pour lui cette rivière au
niveau de la jambe est des faits qui se
sont produits en avril et en mai 2010
neuf de la vinasse pour venant de ce
bassin de décantation s'est déversé dans
le lit de cette rivière
cette situation a provoqué les effets
nuisibles sur la flore et la faune et
engendrer des odeurs nauséabondes dans
tout le secteur
toutes les tentatives des associations
se sont révélées vaines 1 avant de ma
taille et faire nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de monsieur longs mois lui
avons donné des conseils nous lui avons
dit que par rapport à la directive
européenne qu'il y avait la loi qui
avait changé et qu'il devait par rapport
à sa nomenclature mettre son
installation en règle il ne l'a pas fait
aujourd'hui il est condamné et nous
sommes vraiment heureux parce que non
seulement les autres gènes se mettront
en règle et nous aussi nous allons
pouvoir continuer cette pollution
industrielle a exterminé plusieurs
espèces dans ce cours d'eau ce qui a
entraîné véritablement de graves
conséquences sur l'environnement
quelle tristesse de ce bien qu'il faille
en arriver là simplement parce que
des entrepreneurs délinquants pour
fabriquer du rhum détruisent la vie un
empoisonnement de la rivière qui
aujourd'hui est irréversible pour sa
défense le gérant de la sarl parle de
cause accidentelle
en première instance il y a eu une
décision qui est venu relaxé le gérant
sur des problèmes de forme et condamné
la société alors qu'il y avait aussi des
problèmes de forme donc dans un cadre
comme celui là où nous sommes dans un
cadre de communication aussi pénale je
ne peux que vous dire que nous
soumettrons ce dossier à la censure de
la chambre de la chambre criminelle de
la cour d'appel
en outre la sarl la distillerie la
favorite est aussi condamnée à verser à
chacune des associations
la somme de 10000 euros france nature
environnement la fédération des marins
pêcheurs douce mais aussi à la soupe a
marre elle devra aussi régler toutes les
contraventions ayant aussi les frais de
justice